if you're a PC gamer then you're
probably aware of something going on
with CPUs involving security risks and
performance hits researchers at Google's
project zero team shed light on an issue
that affects a wide range of processors
most notably Intel CPUs and while it can
get very technical we're here to
highlight what you need to know about
these CPU flaws and how it will impact
gaming there's a feature that's
fundamentally built into a majority of
processors and prominent in Intel CPUs
at the core of the issue memory is
leaking through the chips kernel which
leads to potential personal data
exposure and increased vulnerability to
malicious software attacks sensitive
information is a sitting duck to malware
particularly what's called meltdown and
specter vulnerabilities the security
flaw was found to be inherent in the CPU
itself it affects the kernel which is a
non-physical entity between the CPU and
operating system that controls
communication between applications and
the hardware itself while the feature
that causes the issue is in CPUs out on
the market today future CPUs could
physically prevent it as of now software
updates have been released to mitigate
the issues since chip manufacturers
can't really do anything about the
design flaws solutions came from the OS
manufacturers security updates to
Apple's Mac OS and Microsoft's Windows
operating systems are now available
additional computational instructions
are patched into the operating systems
to seal the leaks that leave pcs
vulnerable it strongly advised to update
your OS ASAP unfortunately there are
some drawbacks by nature of placing
additional instructions between the CPU
and OS the overall workload is increased
and will slow down processor performance
a ready user on our PC gaming said they
ran their own benchmark test before and
after the Windows 10 security update to
see how much performance was impacted in
a handful of games the claimed loss and
frame rate ranged from as little as 1.5
percent to as large as 13.1% depending
on the game and benchmark these numbers
came from a system equipped with an
Intel Core i5 4690k CPU overclocked at
4.4 gigahertz 16 gigabytes of RAM and an
AMD rx 580 video card the publication
tech spot ran its own benchmarks using
Intel Core i7 8700 K and GTX 10 80 TI
video card before and after the Windows
Update what they found was that the
performance differences were negligible
amounting to almost no difference in
framerate of course the two cases were
using drastically different hardware so
it could be that effects on performance
depend on your PC specs these security
risks affect desktop users server based
systems and even mobile users pretty
much every Intel CPU has this bug and
Apple said that every Mac OS and iOS
device does too but claim that there
aren't any exploits out there yet AMD
claims that their CPUs aren't nearly as
vulnerable to this exploit by nature of
their architecture each company has
released official statements regarding
this widespread problem you can head on
over to GameSpot calm for all the
details in the full story you should
note that this story is developing and
the details could change as companies
dig deeper into the implications of this
issue stick to GameSpot for updates on
PC hardware and how it'll affect the
games that we play